[Applaudissements]
gagner en cohérence pour gagner l'avenir
beau titre n'est ce pas
gagné en cohérence pour gagner l'avenir
un seul titre et deux fois le verbe
gagner c'est prometteur
et les mots cohérence et à venir sont un
peu comme des victoires nan ça nous fait
donc quatre victoires pour un seul titre
gagné en cohérence pour gagner l'avenir
c'est trop beau pour être vrai n'est ce
pas
trop beau pour être honnête ça cache un
truc vous vous dites et pourquoi vous
dites cela pas parce que vous êtes
soupçonneux par nature
pas parce que vous êtes rongé par un
pessimisme un défaitisme à fatalisme
quelconque non simplement vous vous
dites gagner plus cohérence plus gagner
plus à venir abba génial dès le début 4
victoires c'est plié
le gars à peine il monte sur scène il a
déjà gagné quatre fois en plus
et qu'est ce que je fous là moi c'est ce
que vous vous dites madame
quel intérêt si ces jouets davance trop
facile
vous avez raison
toute cohérence et narrative sous tendu
par un scénario
mais vous avez compris la cohérence dès
le départ c'est l'enfer
la victoire dès le commencement avant
même de commencer mais à quoi ça sert
à quoi ça sert de se prendre la tête
d'apprendre de s'aimer de voyager de
travail et de s'engager de lutte et
d'espérer de ruse et de souffrir bref de
vivre si tout est déjà joué d'avancé
vous joueriez vous à un jeu si vous
étiez assuré je veux dire archi sûr de
l'emporter à tous les coups
sérieusement
oui d'accord pour apprendre un débutant
ça se fait mais ça va trois minutes
c'est bon les tutos c'est pas pour les
chiens
jouer sans le risque de perdre ce n'est
pas jouer s'est déroulée où elle
frissons
passé sa vie sans risquer de passer à
côté de sa vie ce n'est pas vivre sait
attendre
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord un film
de deux heures où tout se passerait bien
est un film où il ne se passerait rien
alors pire qu'un navet une daube
insipide
d'ailleurs c'est simple ça n'existe pas
jamais nulle part il ya toujours un
problème au moins un même dans un four
monumental
ce qu'on veut voir dans un film
c'est justement la transformation de la
cohérence en incohérence et la
transformation de l'incohérence en
cohérence il sème la ville et ses parts
ils remuent ciel et terre il se retrouve
on pleure fin
profondément la cohérence et
l'incohérence joue cette dialectique
dont on vient de parler du yen et du
yang
il faut que y est un peu d'incohérences
qui arrive sinon le film ne commence pas
il faut qu'ils aient un peu de cohérence
au final sinon le film ne mène nulle
part
donc vous avez compris que dans cette
dialectique la question du réel se pose
profondément
si le film se passe bien ok on attend le
meurtre la trahison le cyclone le t-rex
les zombies le méchant badass la
kryptonite ou si c'est un film français
le divorce
le dépôt de bilan et si c'est un film
bien bien gore le risque de perdre sa
maison
c'est gore
donc le film tout va bien pour l'instant
tout est raccord cohérent mais
t'inquiète pas ça va partir en live là
ça va commencer vraiment tu la sens pas
la catastrophe et l'art boom
au bilan avis d'expulsion
course contre la montre course contre le
monstre bref le cauchemar
dans la vie c'est pareil on chars bonne
dur pour essayer de matha morphose et
l'incohérence en cohérence un job à
plein temps nos vies sont
cinématographique vous avez remarqué il
ya toujours quelque chose qui se pète la
gueule
une complication une dinguerie une
défaillance
qu'on soit pour vous riche conformiste
ou rebelle de droite ou de gauche il
faut que ça bug à un moment comme au
cinéma boum divorce baum dépôt de bilan
boum la maison il ya toujours un t-rex
qui surgit tôt ou tard c'est ça qui est
passionnant
épuisant mais passionnant
car nous avons besoin de l'incohérence
pour raconter de belles histoires
trop d'incohérences et puise métro de
cohérence rend fou voyez le paranoïaque
ou sa version perverse narcissique le
complotistes personne ne le croit c'est
bien la preuve qu'il a raison
attention hein dès qu'il devient célèbre
à ses élucubrations le deviennent aussi
pour lui la ligne de démarcation est la
suivante il y a ceux qui ne savent
vraiment pas il ya ceux qui ne veulent
pas savoir et il ya ceux qui ne veulent
pas que vous sachiez
être responsable c'est toujours être
responsable de l'incohérence qu'on fait
émerger pour se divertir pour penser en
dehors des clous ou pour éprouver les
limites de notre liberté
en hiver 1999
l'un de mes maîtres en philosophie quand
tout le monde craignait le bug de l'an
2000 me donnait un conseil vincent fait
semblant de croire tout ce qu'on raconte
c'est beaucoup plus marrant
faire semblant de croire faire semblant
de croire aux incohérences pour pimenter
le scénario
mais pas besoin d'attendre là le
sensationnalisme des vérités alternative
très tôt déjà l'incohérence fait
joliment des siennes c'est une
compétence ine regardez les enfants
des petites boules d'incohérences ils
savent pas parler ils tiennent leur
fourchette n'importe comment et c'est ça
qui nous charme il faut tout travers et
on trouve ça attendrissant ils disent
des phrases absurdes au ce chrome union
la vérité sort de la bouche des enfants
faux c'est l'incohérence qui sort de
leur bouche une incohérence sauvage que
nous interprétons comme de la
mignonneries pour ne pas vraiment avoir
affaire à elle oui car nous vivons dans
un monde asphyxié par le diktat de la
cohérence à tout prix une technocratie
sous perfusion informatique qui broie
les fantaisies évalue évacue économise
rationalise et multiplie les clones or
ils sont cohérents les clones
programmables pilotable stockables
jetables cohérent
comme nous sommes
a servi
par le devoir de parent être cohérent
obsédé de cacher nos obsessions d'entrer
dans les normes managériale et les
standards et bien un petit air frais
d'incohérences venant d'un enfant ça
fait tellement du bien un vent de
liberté enfin un enfant un être inadapté
ça existe encore
enfin du bazar dans un monde sûr
organisée du sale et du dysfonctionnelle
dans un monde algorithmique et aseptisée
de la désobéissance du déséquilibre dans
un monde où tous les gens file droit une
promesse de chaos dans un monde où il
faut toujours être ok une promesse de
fatigue non productives de nuits
blanches sans fiesta de parole sans
hypocrisie
les enfants disent les choses comme il
les vives et non comme il convient de
les dire c'est ça la prétendue vérité
qui sort de leur bouche
ils s'en moquent e du devoir de
cohérence et de ses mensonges
masquant le fatras fondamental de nos
amitiés névrosé de nos amours paradoxal
et de nos emmerdes eux sans fin
on n'est pas cohérent avec le réel mais
avec l'histoire qu'on s'en fait
toute liberté humaine
est sous-tendue par la possibilité
exaltante ou tragiques de la cohérence
et la nature fait merveilleusement qu'on
meure
pour qu'une nouvelle génération
remettent le sens en question remette de
l'incohérence dans la boucle ses frais
la mort finalement
j'ai évoqué l'un d'eux mais m un
philosophe maladivement jeune parti en
2018 à 91 ans francis kaplan il aimait
rappeler
toute cohérence n'est pas vrai toute
vérité n'est pas cohérente il ya des
vérités incohérente comme en
mathématiques ou en amour et il ya des
mensonges cohérent comme la belle
interprétation d'un comédien houle en
coupe le mans obligatoire
ce qui compterait c'est le dynamisme
dialectique cinématographique qui
transformerait le bordel en cohérence et
vice versa et tout est dans le vice
versa répétait francis la cohérence
permet l'anticipation et la
compréhension sans lesquels la survie et
la socialisation sont compromises et
l'incohérence devient source de
surprises et de créativité et il en faut
pour aimer la vie
le philosophe déjoue l'incohérence avec
son esprit critique et sa soif de
précisions l'artiste déjoue la cohérence
avec son style et son imagination
le politique devrait s'évertuer à
réduire les incohérences elle comprendra
un jour qu'il a besoin du peuple pour
cela le scientifique et le mystique
cherche des cohérences supérieur
la vie n'est pas tranquille
cure ranger la vie n'est pas un poney
club
transformer l'incohérence en cohérence
réduire la zizanie tapageuse qui nous
environne c'est tout ce qu'on essaie de
faire tous autant que nous sommes tant
bien que mal parfois on réussit et c'est
beau
l'éclaircie entre deux tempêtes séquence
arc en ciel la vie vous sourit l'amour
coule de source on vous respecte on vous
trouve essentiel à la marche des étoiles
vous adorez cette séquence
surtout que vous savez très bien qu'elle
ne durera pas pas longtemps il ya du
patatras qui s'amoncellent à l'horizon
alors vous en profitez vous savourez
vous partagez vous stockez du bon
souvenir et puis
bah patatras
chouette finalement le film reprend le
suspense le t-rex le dépôt de bilan
puis vient un moment dans la vie où
vous avez suffisamment transmuter
d'incohérences en cohérence séquence
arc-en-ciel
permanente à la tombée du jour
alors pour pimenter votre crépuscule un
peu trop serein vous vous intéressez à
aux incohérences des jeunes
vous essayez de les conseiller mais ils
y tiennent tellement à leur incohérence
ils s'en font des montagnes des thriller
palpitant n'allez pas affadir leurs
films il reste aussi un peu le vôtre
on n'arrête pas de créer parce qu on
devient vieux on devient vieux parce
qu'on arrête de créer
alors la seule chose que nous puissions
faire pour aider les jeunes nous qui
avons su gagner en cohérence tout au
long d'une vie tumultueuse c'est
d'accéder à un troisième déploiement de
la cohérence après la cohérence avec soi
même après la cohérence avec les autres
essayé d'être cohérent avec les
générations futures
c'est ça ce que je nomme l'avenir isme
aider ceux qui nous survivront en leur
laissant une capsule temporelle
inspirante le récit de notre combat pour
faire jaillir plus de cohérence quand le
désordre déshumanise et d'incohérences
quand la cohérence robotisée pas de
séquences pop corn donc devant le
spectacle des jeunes
pleins de doutes et d'ardeur l'avenir
east oeuvre pour eux sans relâche avec
les moyens du corps il oeuvre pour les
aider à gagner en cohérence quand tout
s'effondre et meurt il oeuvre pour les
aider à gagner en grain de folie quand
plus rien ne surprend pas même le
bonheur ainsi gagne-t-il l'avenir à
travers eux dans leur scénario dans
leurs souvenirs et dans leur coeur et si
c'était juste ça gagner en cohérence
pour gagner l'avenir
[Applaudissements]